this is rising tides crashing skies
all right it's a Ronaldo episode let's
suit up yeah the second I saw his
silhouette like shit but you the voucher
me I were just like oh we don't pull the
branch oh so it's like you know it's
like every time he pops up I want to
give him a chance cuz I know he's coming
from a good show with good creators and
good writing
honestly the writing is no one even
Orson Welles could occasionally direct a
piece of shit what but okay let okay
even Orson Welles had to do a fish stick
commercial okay and transformers the
movies do you imply that transformers
the movie is as bad as we know of a
small fjord in Norway he must've been so
drunk that they manipulate the voice
like a million times to where he sounds
like dr.kailash
but okay so let's he just let's get this
right the writing in this episode is
actually not that bad because I'm
imagining this writing coming out of a
different character with a little better
timing and you know mastering a little
tighter but it's just killin all those
character is so annoying and not a fun
kind of annoyed there is nothing
likeable about him I mean everything
down to how he's designed how he talks
those voice I just oh it's you know a
part of me all those things this is like
you know cuz every fanbase can have like
annoying fans that complain about
everything method we would or are but
it's something where I know I can you
imagine almost like if you're the
creators of like Steven universe or like
someone just really annoys you either a
fan or a troll or something like that
could you almost see this is some kind
of
venj unlike a well you know I really I
will say this there was an interesting
metaphor with at the very end how
because he's all about hating the gems
he's like a gem hater and then his
brothers like well but not you've gotten
rid of them you have you know there's
there's no reason that for your blog to
exist and I always feel that that's
that's the case with haters whenever I
see some troll or hate or posting I'm
just like oh that's nice we gave you a
reason to exist yeah it's like they
never realized when they're like posting
their comments or something that I'm
like you realize you justified our
existence right just by doing that well
with all this stuff I mean like we we we
complain for a living and then I got
there in the head like one of those
moments where I'm gonna need a drink for
this one by the way where I'm just like
wait a second is that why we're all that
exists fuck but it's just like shit I
mean what else would I complain about
there's not much to complain about on
this baby is only there so you can show
like you know Steven universe the show
speed are made of clay who's Rebecca
sugar to attempt to be like I can't make
it to perfect they'll think I'm a witch
some piece of shit in here I almost feel
like there's this I could probably Rob
but there's this sick joy whatever they
use Ronaldo cuz I found out he's not a
fan favorite a lot of people don't like
him so I get the feeling there's just
like so it's the creators troll yeah
yeah just kind of like they're Joey way
to be a hey you know don't be funny
let's do a run our Ronaldo episode okay
you know what
we said this awesome episode was this
drama honestly and then they said
together with pizza and snacks and some
beers and just watch the comments flow
in varrock times once in a while like
he's certain oh he is like if you took
Michael Moore and Glenn Beck
and put them into one unholy shitstorm
it gave like that we love Bill Maher
yeah just have you count this north to
Kuppa car he doesn't quite have the
sniper but yeah it's like do you Rosen
oi commentators just move down to like
half and really do hate all three of
those people oh yeah yeah neither the
political affiliation oh no I know even
why agree with them it's like I don't
want a fucking grave because I hate you
you're but god help me if ronaldo ever
has a legitimate point cuz i'll but
it'll be like that'll be like i don't
agree with you though like I may just
disagree with you out of spite cuz I'm
imagining some of these scenes like with
the editing and the shaky cam and start
imagining like what if like one of the
gems was doing that or Stephen was doing
that or even con even that like this
would be funny because it's huh cuz we
like these characters but when someone
that's so unlikable as him it's just
constantly like oh the only the only
joke I liked was when he's like I'm
going to the source and like he's like
eight miles away the cameras can hear
them yeah like something I like you two
spending in the chair that was kind of
funny
hey you know him cos fellas consonant
sound oh yeah those are cute I like I
say if this was a different reason all
those jokes came with one although
attached yeah I just I depend on I
cannot put into words how much I hate
this character I'm okay so last night
I've been catching up on Nets files and
there's a character called the trash man
who literally walks in and rips off the
arms of people he doesn't like and
throws them in the garbage I would do
that to run although you know I'm not
too worried that's where I met at this
point the level of hatred is just so I
really like the idea that this could
just be their way of trolling why at
this point a certain way to in some
respects I kind of resent there's no
season - yeah I think I'm season two
isn't it okay so you know the reaction
already I I think it's just their way
we've had so many good episode let's
just let's just fucking with them to do
everything although and don't get me
wrong I respect that that doesn't mean I
have yeah
we've done that a few times with yeah I
totally I totally respect that that
doesn't mean I have to enjoy watching it
i I did a video before Mad Max that a
pair a lot of people really like her
space kinda like it's a when does a joke
go too far as a very serious editorial
but I knew I was gonna do it before bad
max which was gonna attack all like the
men's rights activist and stuff like
that and all these things I was just
like let's just see what happens this
will be my o dare you I am so offended
by it I'm offended you're attacking
group that technically doesn't even
exist and it's love those things where
it's like that was intentional that was
totally done on purpose to see and so
many people are even driving - did you
not see last week's editorial it's it's
totally making fun of you guys no you
just admitted you trauma huh okay I'll
never watch you again until i watch your
next video and then I register bite well
Neil Gaiman was talking about that you
were saying how you know so many people
come out and they say that they hate me
and I hate my work and how come you not
like the old days in seven I said well
that's fine you can go but they never
leave now they're like with every fan
base I mean this is every fan base you
know there's a group of people that are
dedicated to hating it yet they always
watch it for some strange reason they
don't realize it either when they're
doing it that's the fascinating we even
kind of do it too with Downton Abbey we
know the last few seasons have been bad
but it's like we still watch well at
some point though becomes like a train
wreck
you're just what's the last two it's
like okay we got it we got to ride this
out we got right out the last season
we've we've sat there all the other ones
if we couldn't be any more white yeah it
is the whitest thing we've ever done and
we are pretty friggin why eat Oh got
Maggie Smith man well thank you smart or
your show your pretty white or is it
Dame Maggie Smith ah who cares I'm wide
enough already I don't need to get it
right those who have been knighted by
Her Majesty do well good you figure that
out about down Abbey so yeah it's it's
pretty obvious what we thought of this
one I really hate that man I like I said
I might I might respect her a little bit
or just thinking that this is just their
attempt at trolling us in which case I'm
Kelly
nothing to do with respect it has to do
with do I like watching it no I could
tell it I've seen things we're like the
best Oscar telecast ever was James
Franco and it was also the worst but he
was totally fucking trolling the Oscars
I'm like I totally respect that even
though objectively I would say this is
the worst
Oscar telecast I've ever seen will see
him do it again the disaster artist but
I bet they'll be you know what's been
troubling us for years to perfect joy so
what are you talking about done ha ha ha
oh hi Doug
so sex life renard old Ren old I can't
say his name that's how much like I
don't like I dunno wanna say his name
right so yeah there it is ruh ruh yeah
Ronaldo here's to the next episode
Ronaldo's retired oh that's really good
you gotta fight this Oh